the first thing I say is overall and
this was your best done section so good
for you okay
however the devil was in the details I
think with this this question with this
topic right so it started off fairly
gentle you notice we always supply you
what the substitution should be okay so
you should take that cue and go ahead do
your substitution but you know make sure
you do that properly and know what your
derivative is and how to pop that back
into your integral okay so for Parts A
and B I thought that was okay in fact I
thought Part B was extremely generous
because extension one students I
recognize should be able to hand you
that question without a substitution and
you'll be able to work it out because if
you have a look this is in the form once
you do a slight rearrangement to it on
it this is in the form F dash on F right
two units students as tuna students we
know what the derivative of log is
that's F dash on FC we want to want to
recognize that one by now but we were
really handing that to we really want
you to get that question okay so Part A
and B we're fine Part C was where the
wheel started to fall off so here's what
our answer looks like you can see which
so you can see you've got to do more
work because what kind of integral is
Part A it's it's definite it has
boundaries which means you have to
change those boundaries as well when you
change everything from X's into use
you've got to change the boundaries into
use as well so you can see there's it's
not much work we've given you nice exact
values don't forget you are performing
calculus on this so that's why my angles
come out as as radians right they're not
in degrees so just make sure you note
that okay once you got there there this
was a really nice straightforward
integral so that was okay the most
problems were with the boundaries okay
but when we have a look at Part D this
is this is where we had some sub stage
for trouble now let me let me walk
through this carefully okay now I'm just
going to come out right the gate here
and say you kind of got lucky on this
one because there is a being curveball
right in the middle of this question but
it just so happened that we didn't
really put that many marks on this as
three marks and so if you missed the
curveball which 95% of people did we
kind of let it go because you still came
with the right answer but let me explain
you'll see the Cowboys we go through
okay so here's where we begin you have
to change this from X's into use and I
think most of you knew how to use the
substitution to change all of this
business okay so that was fine you can
see me doing it over here on the right
hand side you'll also notice you could
make you the subject you're used to
finding out what D you on D X's because
U is the substitution but in this case
it's actually easier to calculate DX on
do you do you see that because you don't
need to have any square root of x plus 2
flying around no plus or minus to deal
with okay so that was not too bad ok we
had a few issues changing the 3x plus 5
a lot of us kind of looked at and
thought oh that doesn't look like what
it's supposed to look like well as you
can see in order to try and get it close
to 3x plus 5 doesn't require too much
adjustment I multiplied the substitution
they gave us I multiplied it by 3 on
both sides I noticed they that gives me
a plus 6 not a plus 5 so I subtracted 1
on both ends ok so this is what you
should have gotten and you can see that
coming in over there on the left hand
side ok now here's where the major
curveball came in and you just got lucky
okay when you go and have a look at your
new boundaries let me squeeze in over
here here's me working out what my
boundaries were and what they will
become ok now because you start from
negative 1 & 2 you pop that into where X
is but because the substitution you've
been given is U squared u squared well
each of the expounder YZ has two
possible u boundaries that come with it
right because you're solving for u
squared plus minus 1 are both solutions
same thing over here when you solve for
u squared equals 4 so this plus minus
here a significant number of you noticed
it and then artfully ignored it now you
kind of got lucky here because if you
did what most people did and just took
the positive value as you'll see in a
second it comes out in the wash okay but
I will show you actually what you should
have done to get full full marks and you
just got lucky so let's have a look over
here don't worry about this for a second
we'll come to it
let's look at the positive case this is
what the vast majority of you did who
got full marks and this would have been
fun ok when you pop in your new
boundaries for you instead of X this is
not negative 1 it's just 1 so that looks
good you change all of this now
most of you just put in you there okay
because what's on this denominator it's
the square root have a look at your
original question of you squared now the
square root of U squared often is just u
but it isn't always is it and I'll come
back to that isn't always in a minute
however if you did this you can see the
use will cancel that two comes out the
front so you don't need to worry about
it 3u squared you know to integrate math
you an alarming number of you looking to
forgot to integrate this guy all right
that's why the brackets are kind of
helpful to remind you you're doing the
whole thing it's part of the integrand
and then you sub your values in you
evaluate you get twelve okay so that's
fine good for you okay however let me
rewind up here x plus two is u squared
right so when you pop it into u squared
here and you have the square root of U
squared what you really should put is
not you but the absolute value of U this
is in fact one of the definitions of the
absolute value of whatever it's the
square root of the square okay so this
is really what you're supposed to do but
if there's an absolute value sign there
right
we know that absolute values are equal
to do different things depending on
what's inside the absolute value
depending on what values of U you put in
okay so in fact you can't just go ahead
and cancel these guys because they're
not the same once an absolute value one
is not okay you have to decide is this
going to be plus U or is it going to be
- you okay now if you did what most of
you did and just said well I'm going to
take the positive values for the
boundary the positive values of U the
absolute value of a positive number is
just that number right the absolute
value of U will just be you okay but if
you said how do I know I've got to take
those those boundaries and not these
other ones if you looked at this and say
well what do I do with these negative
values if you're looking at negative
values for you for your boundaries and
you're going to substitute them into
here the absolute value is not just you
it's negative U so you might like to
write down for yourself sorry the
absolute value of U is equal to it's
this sum it's this jekyll-and-hyde thing
right that changes what it is depending
what you put in so it is you if you is
positive it is negative you if you is
negative
okay so missing this you guys kind of
got lucky if you just kind of ignored it
free max it's not enough for us to deal
with this you can see how much work
results from dealing with both cases but
this is what you would have done if you
wanted to do it properly you'll notice
that my U and my negative u have
cancelled leaving me with a negative
sign I could just leave that in all the
way and then evaluate but instead I used
one of my properties of definite
integrals do you remember this if you
had a negative sign at the front of a
definite integral you can switch the
boundaries from A to B to B to a do you
remember that it was awhile ago now that
we learned this property of definite
integrals so I've done that in my
working you can see it all still comes
out in the wash we still get the twelve
that you would have got if you did it
the normal way but this is something
which you have to it's a it's a very
sneaky question to sneak in there okay
but that's what it is
all right it's worth noting that any one
who lost marks on this question which is
a fair number of you tended to lose it
anyway
without any of this absolute value
business in here but you should still
know about it okay that's all the
question one does anyone have any
integration by substitution questions
right turn to the next oh yeah Decker
that's a great question
okay so just in case you didn't catch
what Declan said right hey he lost marks
he didn't receive marks because he put
well it'll be here wouldn't it someone
like you okay all right now what's going
on why is it bad to put you squared here
okay as in as in all questions you have
to read the wording carefully what is it
that actually asking us to do right now
when you have a look at in fact all four
parts here they say what are the verbs
there are two verbs they use they use
either find or evaluate right now in
those cases what you're looking for is a
value of something right that's in fact
what evaluate means and find is just a
synonym for that okay in no case for any
of these particular questions have we
ever said it has anything to do with
what are our other common uses for
integrals area or volume right so it
hasn't said it's an area has its editor
volume so it would be a little bit like
me saying you know if I ask you if you
ask me uh you know how many how many
doughnuts have you eaten today and I
said five centimeters you'd be like I
don't think you understand the question
right um I may well have eaten five
doughnuts but the way I've answered that
question shows you I've missed what you
were actually kind of talking about and
five centimeters worth of doughnuts
would be really sad anyway so anyway
that's why the units do matter so little
thing